so you know when you ask me about the
gang thing i want to say yeah i
associate with them if that's okay with
you
we can say it however you want to say it
uh all right junior yes sir junior
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally from orange county santana
and tell me about your family yeah mom
and dad uh mom and dad's still alive uh
hard working mexican family
uh brother and sister
i i could say i lived a good life you
know
good childhood
a good childhood
uh just uh
bad people surrounding me
do you uh
you took through the streets yes sir
what age that start happening i started
really young probably um
my eighth grade year and junior high
school
i uh i started uh meeting people here
and there and that's when i first
started smoking marijuana
i tried cocaine when i was a
freshman in high school
and then it just kind of escalated from
there yeah
you get like jail time prison time yes
sir when they started
i started at uh
18
i went to county uh for drugs
uh
then i got busted for robberies
um
drug sales stuff like that
how much time have you done
i've done a couple terms in prison i've
done a lot of county time
i've
i've been to a few i've done a couple
violations in prison
like l.a county i've been in l.a county
i've been to san bernardino county i've
been to orange county so are the are the
is la county i hear terrible things
about l.a county jail that is worse than
prison
i'll put it to you like this
took me two days just to get a bed
i had to sleep in cement
like this bench
for
almost 50 hours before i even got to bed
so yeah and i've seen some rats
in there
i don't know how they got in there but
there was rats in the cells
i remember i was in the old county jail
there was four bunks and there were six
people in the in the cell
so yeah it's bad
so what is it i mean you had family you
had mom and dad yes but but still the
streets were attractive uh it wasn't
even that it was just uh my parents
worked
i had so much free time to myself
and uh
my parents
my dad cannot read or write so it never
really helped me with my homework so i
didn't care about homework or doing this
and that
and then i had my friends here hey come
over here let's go let's go do this all
right let's go boom so i started going
that direction
what do you blame most is it just the
friends you had
uh you know what i don't
i'm not that person that blames other
people because we all have a choice
i just i i
for a long time i blamed my dad because
he didn't have time for me
but it was just it was really just
i just i just made poor decisions i i
i didn't maximize my time for positive
stuff it was always negative stuff i was
always trying to find
the next hustle that's about that's one
thing about me i'm always trying to
hustle i'm always trying to make another
dollar even when i was younger
so because we were poor
so i always try to go that avenue you
know what can i do to make money yeah i
mean
by saying blame i'm assuming that you
have regrets about
some of your decisions i regret i i have
a lot of regrets yeah i regret people
that i've hurt
not only emotionally but physically
um
i regret you know the route that i've
taken
because uh so many people told me i had
potential
and uh
i use all my uh
i don't know i guess my pos my good
traits for negative stuff you know crime
the life of crime
what do you what do you blame most for
the the environment that you created
those decisions that have made you make
those decisions was it the poverty was
it
for for mommy was poverty
i always um even until now i my i feel
my obligations to help my parents so i
was always trying to like well if i
hustle and make money for myself then
that'll take from them
so
you know
i'll do whatever i got to take if i want
the
nice pair of shoes or a
nice phone or
or whatever it was back in the days back
in the days it was pagers so
but like you know
hustling or like robbing or whatever
you're going to do
selling drugs whatever is that
is that just more desirable more
lucrative than i love that life you love
it i love that lifestyle
i even now that i i
kind of like
got away from that
i miss it sometimes really i missed
that phone call when people are like i
need you for this because i know that i
got them wrapped around my finger
you know there was one time i remember
this guy called me he goes i need this
much heroin or whatever and i go well i
can't i'm not gonna go right now i'm
tired he's like really you're gonna let
this much money go to waste i go check
this out i'm gonna hang up the phone
right now i'm gonna go to sleep
in about eight hours when i wake up
you're to be right there on the phone
calling me because you're going to want
it and you know what happened the next
morning
i had about six texas can you please
take care of me now and i go i thought
you didn't know i thought you didn't
need me
all right well where you at well i'm
going to charge you a little bit more
now he's like [ __ ]
i go you want it or not he goes just
bring it
i love i love the fact it was like like
a power trip to me you know where i like
i know they won't need me
they need me more than i need them
and that's what
that used to just the lifestyle was my
addiction it wasn't the drugs really it
was more the lifestyle
you know being able to
girls would call me you know i need this
i need that
come kick it let's party you know people
need me and i think the the the
that's what drove me more into it more
deeper into it yeah i mean i hear so
many people i talk to from these
lifestyles that are so addicted to it
yeah and if you look at the
if you wrote down on paper all the
benefits and all the prices that they've
paid for that lifestyle
it's clear that they should get out no
it's not there's no question it's like
they're they're losing money they're
they're getting robbed and hurt and
risking their lives but they're addicted
to it and they cannot stop yeah that's
the thing with me like uh
i just got out in um
who was this september october i got out
of county in san bernardino i ended up
getting busted in june right here in la
and i had this person
calling me calling me oh i
i need to get rid of they had this
bike that i've never ever seen in
california it was only a special order
bike and they had one and they're gonna
sell it to me so cheap and i made them
wait and i made them wait and i made
them wait they wouldn't you know they
wouldn't sell it to anybody because why
because they knew that
i was gonna bring to them what they
wanted
because a lot like you said earlier uh
people flake
and the one thing about me is i don't
like to flake
and they knew that when i say something
i'm going to do it
you guys have some crazy stories oh yeah
definitely
i tell you a good story
and this one you know
so this guy came comes into county
and he smuggled in drugs
and uh
we have a
written rule where
it's like everything
you always got to pay up the higher-ups
well he wasn't doing
this so i'm going to day room
and i feel my arms stick out
it holds me and it's one of my friends
really good friends
i mean really we're really good friends
and he's like
hey
go [ __ ] them up right now get them out
of here i go all right
so i ran back to myself i put on my
pants
and uh
there's two tears
so i'm sorry
uh there's two tears
so there's a bar like that it's the
second floor there's a bar right here
so i was like all right i got this so i
stood up on this one pick myself up on
that and spiderman it up
and
somebody else was talking to him
you know to distract him so when he
turned around he swung at me
and i cracked him one time boom he fell
bam bam and i just get it i gave it to
him
and uh i heard the cos come in
and they're like get down and they're
just shooting
boom boom boom boom boom boom bob
rappell is just flying by me hitting me
everywhere and i'm not stopping i'm just
giving it to him
and
i heard him say uh
he goes chase him i said
[ __ ] that i'm gonna [ __ ] on myself so i
[ __ ] threw myself on the floor
and these these cops got me they [ __ ]
man handled me they took me to a
to
a elevator room
and they
beat the [ __ ] out of me and they they uh
one thing about them is they don't want
to get [ __ ] around with their time
there so they don't want to do any
reports any paperwork or anything they
beat the shot at me they took me to the
room and they [ __ ] got me with the
hose cold water and they [ __ ] just
put water on me all because of that and
then they put me back in the cell
you know and uh it's it's weird like
especially in county
everybody wants to they just want to do
drugs be high all the time
and it's always like you know it's
always about drugs
drugs are like um
basically what currency is to us on the
streets that's currency in there
you know i've seen a lot of stuff get
done over drugs i've seen a lot of
people get hurt
it's bad
i have a friend named mike
no longer with us
[Music]
go visit him one day
he has these two girls right there with
them
i'm trying to wake him up and they're
like
don't do that do you know how he is
who are you i'm like don't worry about
it
so then i'm like mikey
and she's like oh my god who the [ __ ] is
this guy i'm like don't worry about me
man so when he wakes up he's like what
the [ __ ] what's up
and i go what's up dude
and they're like oh my god you know him
i'm like yeah he goes what the [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] he's a he was used to have
girls you know
and uh
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] you doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] why don't you take care
of my homeboy right here like we didn't
even know who he was like i told you
you know
well mikey had a little bad habit of um
giving women um
xanax
and then
you know
whatever happened happened i don't know
i can't say i've never seen it
and even if i did see it then i would
take care of it myself but i never you
know
and um
ended up getting busted that same day
i got out a few months later
and i find out that um
he uh
he got beat with the crowbar or a pipe
and then thrown over the river the
bridge
when i went in
and i got a few months later
four of the people four people that i
knew from that little area where we hang
out
three got murdered
and uh i'm sorry uh five people and two
in
prison now they're doing life
and it all stand because of drugs
and
i guess you know like the power trip
because one of them um
somebody
use their own power to tell these people
basically
uh
you know that one fiddler or whatever
plane the
and all the mice are following or
whatever
they can you know they can tell people
what to do and the drugs are a powerful
thing
especially when you don't have any and
you need them
with heroin people i've noticed people
with heroin
they uh
because i sell heroin i
they will sell their mother's soul
just to get that fixed so they don't
hurt anymore
and these people they got talked into
doing stuff that they shouldn't have
done
just for you know i mean for their next
fix
you know it's sad if you think about it
as these people died and these other
people that committed the crimes all
those lives got lost
over something so stupid like drugs
this is why i say that i want to change
my life because
thank god i've never got caught but i've
done some crazy [ __ ] like that where
i've hurt people for drugs
and i think back and i'm like man
it was this close from turning into
something fatal
so
were you a disappointment to your
parents
i want to say so for making those
decisions i i i want to say i was
disappointed to my whole family
because uh for a while actually
um
as a young kid i was one of my my best
traits that i had was i was a good
baseball player
and i used to play in the traveling team
and we were undefeated the last year i
played and
it was funny i was telling one of my
friends i go
three of my friends that were on that
team
two are homeless
drug addicts ones in prison for life
and people who see me now from from back
then they tell me we thought you were
going to be a professional baseball
player
i never thought that i always thought
that
i'm going to be a drug addict really i
love the life
i don't want to go through all that
struggles of
going to college and this and that hell
no i want to go party
i just
you know and it sucks because like a lot
of my uncles
even though they love me to death they
uh
sometimes they just i just look at them
and they just shake their hand they're
like
what a waste
was it the lack of raw uh good role
models
yeah
i uh
i don't want to say my dad was a bad
role model because
he's he's a great man he provides and
everything
it was he's just not that type of a
person that's like
you know that person to light the fire
you know i mean that
you know give you that motivation
motivation
and and that's because as a kid he was
abused
he lived poor in mexico
and uh
he wasn't raised by his father so he
doesn't have that
i guess want to say i don't want to say
fatherly instinct but he just never had
that
that role model
never had that person tell him you know
you can't do this you can't do that
my dad was just a
he was a lost soul
basically
did you feel like you had options
uh yes or square life and you know
becoming a
you know doing something with your life
that was not involving the streets yes
i did i had the options
i'm sorry it was boring
yes
it like i said
that feel of people wanting you that
that's more attractive to me than going
to class
you know going to college are you an
adrenal adrenaline junkie yes sir that's
it i i love it
i i it's so much more exciting robbing
somebody than
yeah
you know what it is it's
like i said it's i think it's it's that
uh
power trip kind of
where um you
[Music]
the people are terrified and stuff and
you know you have control of them so
it's like a control thing
so
i think that's what gets me more
it just kind of pumps me up
interesting
yeah i'm sure i'm sure there's some
psychological
i think something some power thing or oh
yeah definitely or feeling needed or
something you know it's like i read a
thing where like
i know like i i remember um i was
reading an article one time about how
people who rape people that they're
right they relish that power they have
over that person at that moment
you know what i mean
and that's
you know that's
it's like they're having it's like a
like a euphoric thing to them
you know for me it's that
the drug dealing
they're doing crime
you know going to the store and
taking something i was just i got money
in my pocket i want to take it just
because i can and nobody's going to stop
me
what was the lowest part of your life
ah
i told this to a friend of mine
recently um
my son
um
he told me uh
you know daddy
mom told me you're a crack kid
you know and my kids looked up to me so
much my boys
two younger ones
um they're from a different relationship
and when he called me that
even though i've never even smoked track
in my life
it just broke my heart like
you know they always thought that dad
was captain america
when i was just another junkie
and that just kind of like
it just if if
even to this day playing a little bit of
mind games with me like
like really like are you really
are you really worthy of being a father
to them yeah i mean like what's going on
with you like
you know what's what's what's up you
know you gotta snap out of it
you know you can't be stuck in this
[ __ ] lifestyle all the time because
it's it's gonna it's gonna kill me which
it has a couple times almost
and
you know i i just couldn't do anymore i
just that just broke me down
were drugs every part of your life drugs
yeah oh yeah you were using oh i've used
all my life oh you have all my life
since i was 12 to about um
about a year ago really yes sir so
you're clean now yes and did that
conversation you had with your son
straighten you out or healthy no it
didn't yeah i had a near-death
experience recently oh wow yeah i was i
just got out it was funny i got out i
got arrested a couple of years ago
when the pandemic started and i had lost
my job or whatever so i did that pua
thing and i got a hefty little amount so
when i got out
i went to this hotel had a bunch of
heroin
a bunch of speed
bunch of syringes and i by myself in a
hotel room
and i decided well you know what
i'm gonna mix these two and just uh
enjoy them both
so i put speed and heroin in a syringe
and i shot up
needless to say that heroin was too
strong for me because i would i just got
out from doing eight months
and uh
i started passing out and i thought i
was gonna die by myself
and at that moment i got scared luckily
i heard a knock on the door and i was
already going out and luckily i don't
know what happened i don't know if
god picked me up or something or what it
was but i was i i got my bearings
together and i was able to walk through
the door and open it and when my friend
walked in he started slapping me around
because he saw me he's like you do
you're pale you're going out and he kept
him he kept me up and i survived
you know i just lost my cousin about a
year ago too the female overdose so i
know how it is that feeling it's the
worst feeling in the world and you know
it's funny it's so cliche that they say
uh
when you're gonna die your your life
passes right through you it did
all i could think about was oh my god
i'm gonna die and i'm never gonna see my
kids again and i could i could just
picture their faces
there's definitely a self-destructive
aspect to the life on the streets right
yes
tell me about how that's played out in
your life
the self-discussion just being
self-destructive self-sabotaging
um
do you find yourself not believing that
you deserve something better than i do
than what you're i'm not trying to i'm
trying to award this for you i i i you
know sometimes i uh it's funny i i've
lost family members
and i remember i was at a funeral one
time and i was talking to my family and
i was like
you know we lost my cousin who's a
marine decorated marine
lost my cousin
and i you know i went into this
thing where i was like
i told the people there i go i don't i
don't understand why good people leave
and people like me that are fuck-ups
keep on getting second chances
you know i don't deserve to be alive
i should be the one in there
he should be
breathing
you know
it's weird how i do all these bad things
and i continue to
the way i look at it i continue to live
on
and good people always go
you know i just sometimes i feel like i
don't deserve life
but i love it
if somebody's protecting you
yeah
what do you worry about
what are you afraid of at this point my
cousin my cousins my kids
go in the same direction
that i go you know it sucks because
sometimes i tell them
look at me look at it look at all the
[ __ ] that i've done do you guys want to
be like me
and i had my son the other day my older
son tell me
well
dad i mean like are we supposed to
listen to you
like
you're telling us not to do something
that you can continue to do
you know who are you to tell us what not
to what and what not to do if you're not
even doing it for yourself
you know it hurts and it sucks because
they're like i'm like [ __ ] you're right
you know it's like
do you think that if maybe if you grew
up in a
city that wasn't so gang infested that
maybe your life would have
taken to the streets i mean the streets
probably don't exist in north dakota
like they do in l.a
probably probably maine or something
like that right
i grew up in in in the 80s 90s i grew up
in in savannah
which was like
[Music]
every corner you go inside there's a
gang
i mean gangs out there are just it's
like a small version of valet county
it's hard not to
you know because i just go to school
where
there's probably close to about maybe a
dozen maybe 15 different gangs in that
junior high school there was fights
after school all the time then i went to
set in high school probably has more
gangs
and i remember i was playing football
he's playing the football team
there'd be
shootings broad daylight two o'clock
two three o'clock shooting boom boom
we're like what the [ __ ] is going on
it would you know
i i
i'd be lying to you if i didn't say that
there's about there was a
maybe close to five shootings a week
in broad daylight people getting shot
this is junior or high in high school
high school yeah two o'clock three
o'clock after school boom boom boom
people waiting outside in cars for their
enemies to come out
oh there he is bam
or stabbings
fights what what is it is it
testosterone that's behind all of this
no it's all these people always you know
we're always fighting about uh oh that's
my street you can't come down my street
yeah but that's that's testosterone yeah
yeah yeah that's what it is it's you
know when i look at it it's an ego thing
especially in men
that's what i'm saying you know our egos
have you hurt our egos
[ __ ] we will go to an extreme to repair
it yeah
no if
you if you remove testosterone from the
equation oh yeah you wouldn't have gangs
right
you wouldn't have gun violence you would
have a lot of things yep
so yeah i guess it's testosterone would
be the thing they're not
if you had your life to live over again
what would you have done differently
looking back now
if i could um
do my life again
maybe maybe do the exact same thing
no
no
i wouldn't listen to those teachers
those
coaches my sports and you know my
parents my uncles i would have listened
to them i would have gone to school
you know i i i i work now
and um
as i'm getting older it's like
you know my dad's like yeah you watch
when you get older you know and now that
i'm getting older it's like [ __ ] it's
it's a hassle just to get up in the
morning
go to work
you know
i just had a hernia surgery that was a
pain like all these things like i would
have gone to school and became a doctor
probably
and not have to worry about all this
hard labor
and all this other crap
and i i could have used you know
i could have helped people
instead of uh
hurting them
what was the best memory you've got from
your life
your favorite memory
probably the birth of my kids
i don't have a lot of good memories um
and you know maybe you've heard that
before but i i don't because like i said
i've been running the streets forever
i've been
homeless you know i mean and not because
not by not because
i didn't have anywhere to be
it was by choice because i wanted to be
in the streets 24 7. really yeah but the
best memories like i said uh are my kids
being born that's about the best thing
because
it's like
wow that's a piece of me
you know let me see if i can mold them
a certain way
you've been in love before
in love
yeah
i'm i'm in love now that's good for you
yeah i'm in love with the woman a great
woman
same lifestyle as me i mean
we met when we were high
not too long ago and uh we were doing
some crazy [ __ ]
and we stuck to each other and now we've
helped each other
we dug ourselves out of that hole and
now we're doing good
it sounds like this might be the best
point of your life
right now yeah
yeah because um
you know i look at it like i got a
little bit of time left to live
how old are you i'm 42 42.
um but uh anytime
yeah i mean depending how i live
you know but uh i think well i'm
actually if i'm i'm probably maximize
more of my life now if i if i go the
right route but uh yeah i it's a good
time
it's a good time
because i was able to beat this disease
again
and when i mean disease i mean uh
i'm a recovering alcoholic i'm a carbon
drug addict
so were your drugs oh anything that was
water soluble
you know i mean anything i would try
i've tried anything you can think of
except crack for some reason
yeah but uh i've done it all
i've done it all
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
you know you cherish those people that
actually care about you you know
because um
there was a one time in my life that i i
remember i moved out i went to my
uncle's house
and my uncle couldn't put up with he
like i'm not putting up with you you got
to go
there's nobody's going to put up with
you except your parents doesn't matter
what you do they'll still love you
they'll still take care of you they'll
still house you or whatever they're the
ones that are always going to be there
for you
and those are the people that i took
for you know i mean i took advantage of
the most and i regret it
so yeah you know
[Music]
it's just even thinking about right now
it's hard that's why to this day i try
to do everything i can for them now
because i know they try to do everything
they could to help me out
even in my
rock bottom days
yeah forgiveness is a is a key component
of
living a happy life i think yeah
forgiving yourself for giving your
parents forgiving everyone
all right junior thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah i wish you the
best of luck thank you thank you
you